Christopher Nolan is notorious for using
real life effects as much as possible
visual effects supervisor Nick Davis
spoke to Studio daily saying Nolan
didn't want the film to take on a
gimmicky visual effects look the only
visual effect involved in that scene was
to remove the ram that they had built
inside the truck but the Dark Knight
still offered some unique CG challenges
when it came to creating the look for
Harvey two-faced Dent Nolan wanted to
remove layers not add them the VFX team
had to digitally remove the skin two
faces exposed eyeball had to be
painstakingly animated by hand as were
the subtle changes in muscle tension